bien le bonjour les amis comment
allez-vous p'tit kawa qui met bien toi
même tu connais le matin au mans vous
regardez cette vidéo comme vous le savez
je suis dans l'avion direction la corée
mais là où je la fais je suis une
semaine avant [ __ ] ça après un fois de
ma vie que je prends de l'avant ce sont
mes devoirs c'est bon j'ai eu une idée
on va tenter on est dans la propre à
l'entente de quelque chose je me suis
dit quoi de mieux avant de visiter un
pays que de regarder son top des chaînes
youtube
je suis au regret sur ce sable hell.com
et voici le classement des chaînes
youtube coréenne
parce que oui encore et ils sont aussi à
fond sur youtube au japon par exemple
ils sont un peu moins sur youtube ils
ont ainsi que s'appelle nico nico et
genre sur les lives ya des centaines de
milliers de personnes quand tu écris un
commentaire ça s'affiche en direct sur
l'écran mais t'as pas besoin de faire un
nom ne s'est pas des escrocs n'ont donc
la première chaîne c'est big bang
je connais un peu tout ce qui est con et
parce que j'ai quelqu'un autour de moi
qui adore ça et je sais donc que big
bang est un groupe de kpop donc ça c'est
la première chaîne et ça c'est un petit
peu finalement comme du david guetta des
chaîne vevo et c'est ça qu'on ne passe
pas des youtuber il ya une semaine 20
millions de vues ça va ça va je mets à
kheops bon regarder un petit extraire
le but n'est pas tout
et à la main
ok ok ok bon voilà c'était la laque et
pop mais je suppose que le top 10 des
premières chaînes en fait à être que les
chefs de groupe de quelques profs c'est
tellement le truc qui cartonne encore et
dans le monde alors deuxième chaîne
c'est de la [ __ ] le troisième sm town
c'est là qu'est pop on va tomber sur des
gens normaux comme nous un jour c'est
promis bon alors à faire un petit bout
de culture en gros sm town c'est une
agence qui forment des coréens pour
qu'ils intègrent plus tard un groupe de
hip hop qui deviennent des stars
six groupes marche ou pas et l'asm tain
c'est une agence qui possède notamment
le plus grand groupe de kpop de corée
qui s'appelle epso
[Musique]
bouffées que ça n'inquiète pas car cette
vidéo est ya des youtuber à des puceaux
comme squeeze qui font des vidéos là bas
alors si elle aime music officiel non
sur kbs voir thiviers d'accord donc
c'est une chaîne youtube qui
appartiennent télé ils font des lives
butt leur télé elle est reliée aussi
influent en live sur youtube mais son
dole food hyacinthe rigaud
c'est génial plutôt que c'est ballack et
papa on note hockey ensuite c'est quoi
ça la k-pop ne prenez pas pour un coût
c'est pas un hacker pape ça dans ses
peintures de beauté ça c'est vraiment
pas tu te botter ô mon gars alors attend
donc les six premières chaînes c'est de
là qu'est pop sous une housse est une
chaîne télévision et la 7e c'est ça oh
[ __ ] un million d'abonnés et cd dessin
animé c'est ça sans me ottan celui-là
peser auprès des 4 8 ans il ya eu un
gros buzz on en parlait à la crèche
c'est en anglais madame mec
en fait c'est un truc s'adresse
totalement un public anglophone mais
sauf que les mecs ont créé cette chaîne
ses décors r c'est tout pour rojo 8e
chaîne de corée 70 millions de vues par
mois
[Musique]
ça c'est bien
je sais que ça fasse môquet est là c'est
bon c'est dans un climat s'est un temps
de séchage ou société suppose et bio
sponso ça fait ça que pour la thune
encore et aussi one million dance studio
9e chaîne de corps et ça c'est un studio
de danse et les plus talentueux de corée
il me semble est il fondé des
chorégraphies sur des chansons bas de
caisse pop ou autre il paraît qu'ils
dansent presque aussi bien que moi
ouais déjà tu redescends sérail ou
ajouté j'ai eu l'électricité dans la
forme mais ça veut dire quoi qu'on
allait tenir la jambe
julien maynial s'il te plait je suis
honnête chaîne youtube tu l'a jamais dit
ça en vidéo un docteur quelqu'un vous
dites le moi dans les commentaires
moi je trouve pas l'état de mes vidéos
le matin ils sont carrément trop chaud
quoi à rien ils ont fait du rihanna
ils ont fait du rihanna c'est bon c'est
bon jeu ok vous avez gagné vous avez
gagné vous allez gagner je mets quoi je
m'amuse mais quoi lever le pouce bleus
poussent bleus au jeu mais auquel mais
pousse bleus et là je vais faire traiter
de pervers sur tout cas pendant une
semaine jusqu'au moment où vous voyez
cette vidéo karine toys c'est la dixième
les amis j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette
vidéo en découvrant la chaîne de carihem
toys ses studios bulting mais sans les
enfants et juste avec le père voilà
c'est une coréenne qui fait parler des
histoires avec des figurines sauf que
c'est pas en paix au v comme l'autre
c'est filmé de face ou avec on la voit
vu que les cultures diffèrent vachement
un truc pour nous va sembler bizarre
chelou alors pour eux c'est la norme
quoi à une clio jentzsch
[Musique]
je suis une [ __ ] j'avance dans la vidéo
comme ça moi le truc à avoir contexte
faut qu'on ait des connards vous aussi
[Musique]
400000 but à rien et ça fait vraiment
beaucoup de faits parce que les enfants
il sûr qu'il en fait
regardez il ya 10000 j'aime et tout mais
normand sèchement passé pas moins des
enfants ils sont ils regardent mais ils
commandent pas émettre pas de gm ni rien
sur youtube
regardez les vidéos dessins animés kitan
sur youtube il ya très très peu de deux
communautés en fait vu que ces enfants
juste ils regardent et la mort voilà les
adultes approuve quoi voir les enfants
de 6 ans ils sont déjà là écrire
tranquillement coréen à like et chef
trop mais qui peuvent à parler leur
train de mourir sous un truc il fait des
gestes on sent qu'ils s'énervent la
halle oubliée tu le prends la base il a
mélangé avec lui avec du talent un truc
comme ça tu sais qui gisent pas cela qui
souffrait de nuit près tu arrêtes cette
pauvre pattes
ok suivant m net et pop au bidule tv et
youtube heures originale sur minecraft
[ __ ] enfin quoi enfin donc le premier
ou du beurre gaming est la 1 million 300
mille abonnés là bas c'est bizarre parce
que pourtant la corée c'est le pays aux
jeux vidéo enfin je veux dire c'est là
bas où il ya le plus de progrès moeurs
où les meilleurs joueurs 10 sport c'est
carrément des rock stars de ouf ya
toutes les filles qui rôdent autour
comme comme carrie par exemple à mon
avis sont beaucoup plus ils se portent
que le mec qui fait le compte dans des
jeux vidéo genre moi là bas serait
carrément chômage d'accès il fait que
minecraft gtb c'est entertainment s'est
extrait de télé tu as il ya très peu de
tueurs en fait dans le top un vrai nous
séparait ya beaucoup de chaîne vevo
d'artistes etc
prat ping pong mais on n'a pas vu au
tout début ping font qu'ils sont gagnent
stories ping pong assez la même chaîne
que tout à l'heure
sauf que là les titres et les vidéos
soient en coréen et ça marche mieux au
mode world wide en anglais que encore et
encore et un os un gamer encore une
chaîne en kraft mais c'est incroyable
niveau entertainment genre pas
compétition il ya que minecraft quoi qui
marche c'est ou fin c'est marrant c'est
ce que je vous dis ça change bouge pour
les pays c'est ouf
marseille fait beaucoup de minecraft
mais il a fait d'autres jeux toutes les
20 vidéos il dit vas-y je vais quand
même pas faire quel mannequin en fait il
ya très peu de youtube heures les amis
je suis hyper déçu il big hit ça je
connais c est ce que c'est faites un
petit effort de la kpop avec un budget
de clips qui s'élève à 100 millions
d'euros ça fuse et les moyens qui mène
on voit que c'est que ça cartonne quoi
regarder s aidant blanche veut dire
traitement il a dû coûter cher djoko
fait écouter je pense qu'on a fait le
tour il ya essentiellement des chaînes
de télé et des chaînes de kpop et des
chaînes pour enfants à écouter et
apprécier la fin de cette vidéo voilà on
s'est instruit finalement on en a appris
un peu plus le pays dans lequel je suis
en train d'aller alors vous voyez cette
[ __ ] de vidéos comme promis je vous
ferai un petit velours là bas
et puis venir là bas j'aurais que c'est
des trucs de fou quoi ils ont beaucoup
de respect pour les mecs font des
conneries demandé dans des jeux vidéo
gratuits
j'étais pâmé dos ça vous a plu reçurent
très vite dans une prochaine portez vous
bien profitez bien de vos petites
vacances vos petits cadeaux tous à judas
trith tu as tout le monde
vittel
[Musique]